okay das video jetzt losgeht eine ganz
kurze sache und 20 einem jahr gekündigt
das nichts für jeden tag während des
urlaubs hier einen blog auf einem kanal
raushauen werde leider leben nicht nur
wie auf dieser insel sondern auch sehr
viele andere und auch sehr viele
zuschauer von mir
[Musik]
auf jeden fall war und habe auf jeden
fall einige fans verfolgt und wirklich
nicht nur einfach und auf der straße
gestanden was auch schon so bald wie
sondern auch teilweise irgendwie zum
haus noch mit hin und irgendwie direkt
fast mit reingekommen und so das war
nicht so cool und das lag leider daran
dass ich ein bisschen viel gezeigt haben
von unter anderem aus haus hier dafür
auf jeden fall der grund warum ich mir
gedacht habe okay ich werde keine blogs
vor und laden wird jetzt einfach ein
bisschen schirm bisschen urlaub machen
aber dann habe ich diesen wundervollen
lektüren in meinem schlafzimmer gefunden
in der jugendherberge wir haben hier
nämlich einmal es klopft bei wanja in
der nacht und bhf liebster buchau
gefährde er ist werden wir euch heute
vorlesen also willkommen zu lukas
lesestunden würde sagen ich drücke
selber das buch in die hand und wir
fangen an mit der ersten zeile des buchs
weit fort in einem kalten land steht man
das haus lenkte sein das waren wir heute
morgen machen so gehört er das hier sind
wir erst bei sturm im finstern single
instruction
wir besitzen das für den kollegen als
ist er heute morgen bayerischen
abgefahren ist und irgendwie verfolgt
der uns aber trotzdem hört also sein
geistiges immer noch da ist bei sturm im
finstern von vorne der ist bei sturm im
film der mann ja plötzlich auf der bühne
das ist typisch natürlich geht er jetzt
hier ab was höre ich da trocken so fragt
er sich erschrocken wer ist der kopf
klopft daran sein haus für ein hase
kocht im schneesturm daraus der streit
und glücklich die real gewann er sagt
kommt nur herein ich heiße sie gleich im
ofen an die wärme dringt bis in die haut
moment moment moment was hat waren ja
vor mit dem hasen waren wir als wir
machen jetzt eine kurze exklusion zu
werden trotz seiner kleinen körpergröße
ist das shetlandpony ein kräftiges und
cs tieres pony übersteht das raue klima
der shetland islands land das gutmütige
kleinen fertig kann auch sehr gut von
kindern
wer stellt sich wirklich auf wanja deck
dich wieder zu gut nach und angenehmen
also irgendwie fing das ganze buch an
das wanja nach hause kam und irgendwie
die die bude eigenheiten jetzt wieder
überall besoffene tiere unterdessen tobt
weiter wie besessen
neben dass dieses mächtige kaltblutpferd
ist das größte aller fairness kann ein
stockmaß von über 2 meter haben wollen
mein schwanz
[Gelächter]
videos jetzt wirklich noch mal ein
bewegender text hier ohne das pferd wäre
der weg des menschen in die zivilisation
weitaus mühsamer gewesen wäre man kann
sich heute kaum noch vorstellen dass
viele lebensbereiche früher einmal vom
pferd abhängig war nach toren gab es
leute die befürchteten man würde werde
in zukunft nur noch im zu betrachten
können doch im gegenteil waren die fälle
früher bei der arbeit unentbehrlichen
sie den menschen heute als partner in
freizeit und sport turniere und
pferderennen 7 tausende von besuchern an
es gibt viele zuchtvereine die sich um
die erhaltung alter oder besonderer
pferderassen bemühen und fast jedes kind
träumt einmal davon ein eigenes pferd zu
besitzen
an der stelle würde ich das heute die
videobänder